foreign
[Music]
my name is Lisa hazeldine and I'm the
spectators Assistant online editor each
week here we'll be looking at a topic in
depth that we don't think is getting
enough attention
this week I'm joined by Alexander larman
author and books editor for The
Spectators World Edition
last week he wrote about why the film
Avatar 2 has confounded the critics for
spectator life
Alexander thank you so much for joining
me
so firstly could you tell us a little
bit without any spoilers what Avatar 2
is all about
well Avatar 2 is the sequel to the
highest grossing film of all time
fittingly called Avatar and essentially
it's following the action of the
original film about a decade on and it's
still set on the planet Pandora and as
for the first film the nari family or
have you pronounce it is threatened by
the forces of colonialism and it's not a
subtle film I think it's fair to say
it's big and it's blue and it's long one
Garden review said there was a
thunderously damp squib of a return and
also another Telegraph review sort of
called it like being waterboarded with
turquoise cement which quite strong
um
quite strong sort of opinions why do
they hate it so much because it's not
very good I mean it's what's so sad is
that James Cameron was for decades one
of the most exciting filmmakers in
Hollywood he was a man of incredible
visual gifts his films were kinetic they
were exciting what he did with special
effects was absolutely incredible these
days he seems to have lost his way and I
think unfortunately we have to go back
to Titanic in 1997 as a turning point
for that because Titanic is many things
it's very accomplished film but it's
also a film of an absolutely terrible
script and then he has barely made any
film since maybe he's two Avatar films
which also have terrible scripts the
first Avatar film which came out about
13 years ago at least had the virtue of
having an interesting and dynamic
original idea and it came out of a dawn
of 3D as well but what's been so
interesting is that I am on record the
same level Avatar 2 would flop because I
thought who's going to care about it who
was going to care about this return to
the cinema 2 billion dollars later I'm
laughing at the other side of my face it
shows but James Cameron whether you love
or hate him understands what audiences
want and the quality of the film doesn't
really matter because what you're buying
into I think is an experience and you're
buying into Cinema as theme park I see
yeah I mean I guess also particularly
Titanic even now over 20 years later
it's such a cult
film
um
in a way I guess they're perhaps there's
an element of anything that he were to
do afterwards would also be quite hard
out to follow precisely because of how
popular it's been but I wonder then so
why do the credit critics get it wrong
you know why has it confounded them I
suppose critics are looking at it in a
different way how audiences are looking
at it because under I suppose I include
myself in this as a Critic you're seeing
a film often in the company of other
critics and there is a general sense
that you're quite cynical people you're
often seeing the films at half 10 in the
morning on a Monday and it's not the
best way to see a film because you're
not getting any kind of audience
expectation from it but also there's a
fact that as a Critic you see a lot of
films and when something really does
stand out both for good and bad you
really notice it so Avatar 2 perhaps
isn't appealing so much to people who
are seeing three or four films a week
because they have to it's pink to the
kind of people who would go for Cinema
maybe once a month if that who wants a
big experience because essentially
you've got imagine if you take your
entire family to see Avatar too it's
going to cost quite a lot of money
tickets popcorn and parking and what
have you but what you're getting in
return is you're getting an experience
you go in it's in 3D if you go to the
IMAX that's going to be a huge sensory
experience and actually questions of
whether it's any good don't really count
so much as well like if you go and have
a McDonald's it isn't going to be any
good but you're getting an experience I
mean you might not want the experience
but the nonetheless is clearly something
that is going to be different and it's
going to be something that actually you
might quite enjoy once in a while I like
that comparison to McDonald's
still sort of that easy dopamine here
um again I guess I was wondering you
touched on the 3D side of it too and you
talk about it in your piece a little bit
but just wondering could you expand why
do you think it is that's a 3D seems to
have had its moment and gone what was
fascinating is when Avatar one came out
3D was just coming back because it
starts off from the 1950s as a means of
desperate Cinemas trying to compete with
television and it was of course a
novelty I mean technology advanced to a
point you didn't have to have for you
know the novelty aspects anymore but it
could be a far better way of showing a
film but everybody including me for the
3D was done because films were not
really coming out in 3D at anymore I
mean something like so top gun Maverick
which made a big deal about its visual
Powers being those for iMacs not for 3D
seemed to be the way forward so
Cameron's coming back what he says
essentially as well I did it okay 13
years ago look how brilliantly it worked
and the words agreed with him so I
suspect we would actually expect to see
more free TV films again between Avatar
2 and Amazon 3 which is are if you think
about it but it's also a testament if
you are somebody who is so powerful
these films do consistently bring the
box off his successes I mean the fact is
he has barely made any films over the
last few decades but they're all going
to be in the you know top 10 and even
top five possibly lifetime it does
settles highest grossing films of all
time and that is a phenomenal
achievement so whatever we might say
about not liking the films you can't
donate over here's you know tickling the
collective g-spots I mean it really is
something quite extraordinary he's doing
yeah absolutely and I wonder sort of on
that front I think I'm right and saying
there are three sequels lined up after
this one do you not think there's a
chance though the audience will get
bored of it by that time I hope so but
the saddest thing I saw was I've been
praying but Cameron will stop making
Avatar films go and do something else
but as soon as I saw him saying well the
success means we're all green lit now I
thought God because the rest of a decade
that's all he's doing and he's he's not
a young man anymore I mean he's in his
late 60s and I've often wondered I mean
all his films have been big spectacles I
mean since the Terminator 1984 he's
never made a film which is people
sitting in a room talking I mean they're
big immersive special effects films but
after one wouldn't it be interesting not
to have an avatar not to have had
anything like that something perhaps
closer to Titanic or even closer to
something like True Lies which I think
is actually quite an underrated film
although it's a racial politics don't
play very well these days
so I guess the message is buckle up
we've got a lot more blue to come blue
blue electric blue I'm afraid indeed
um so I wanted just to sort of Branch
out the conversation a little bit
um so we then
if you had to put all the ingredients
that make a hit film into a pot what
would those be particularly from an
audience perspective what is it I guess
the audiences are looking forward to
make that hit film well William
Goldman's famous dictator about
Hollywood is nobody knows anything and I
think what's quite interesting is that
at the moment the films would do well of
those that Marvel and Disney are
releasing I mean if you look at the
absolute dominance because Disney of
course own 20th Century Fox who are
responsible for Avatar most films that
have been successful at the box office
in the last half many years have been
either Disney produced or Disney
released so they clearly understand the
what audiences want and what is doing
well at the box office well superhero
films sequels lots of special effects
things which basically play into a wide
lowest common denominator audience
we have old anomalies I mean top gun
Maverick although it is a sequel the
sequel to a film that was 35 years old
so that's not as if people were queuing
up to demand that 35 years on we have to
see another Top Gun film it's absolutely
tremendous I mean it's the anti-avatar
too as far as I'm concerned it's a film
that every single frame of it is
absolutely suffused with excitement and
Innovation and it's a brilliant
brilliant film but what it also has is
it has Tom Cruise at its heart and I'm
on record that's writing about Cruz that
he is the last remaining Hollywood film
star and we have moved on from the star
system which we had as recently return
of a millennium I mean nobody cares for
Sam worthington's in Avatar Avatar 2 it
could be literally anybody because
ultimately first of all he's blue and
under special effects and secondly as an
actor he's barely registered in anything
live action so we take away the idea
that people care about movie stars
anymore they don't that's what they care
about now is they care about Brands they
care about you but intellectual property
which can be turned into theme parks can
be turned into anything else and I think
crucially two the idea that you don't
have any off-screen Scandal because if
you look at the Black Panther sequel
wakanda forever that film is stymied by
two things first of all fact that it's
original Star Trek Roseman died between
making the first one and second one
being made secondly believe that just
Leticia Wright was a well-known
anti-vaxxer and things like that are
really getting in the way so my film did
very well of a box office but nowhere
near as well as the original was quite
unusual because generally speaking
sequels do better than the original
because you've got all of the affection
for first one plus the excitement of the
new one so I think for what you can see
now in Hollywood is studios are playing
it safer than they have ever done before
which means you get conservative boring
films I'll expect somebody who's
suggested Cinema most weeks there isn't
enough to go and see now because I'm not
interested in what's being released
because it's just not as good as it used
to be I mean Cinema is in a a declining
spiral and I have no idea when it's
going to get better
how much do you think streaming Giants
have a part to play in that is can is
there an element would it be fair to say
of
films that are being produced now being
angled toward more towards the type of
thing that people search for when they
go to a streaming giant like Netflix or
Amazon Prime or is it something
completely unrelated that's sort of
causing this well streaming has it has
an upside and a downside because on for
one hand for people like Netflix and
apple can offer veteran filmmakers like
say a Ridley Scott a Martin Scorsese or
David Fincher as much money as they want
to make their dream projects I mean for
instance really Scott's making the song
about napoleons coming out so either
late this year early next year it
doesn't matter what it does of a box
office because Apple have whatever 200
250 million dollars to invest in a film
like that and it doesn't matter if
nobody goes to see it at the cinema
because it's whole purpose is it is
going to be the reason why you get a
subscription travel TV set against this
Ridley Scott is making a film at
Napoleon that's a film to go and see in
the cinema that is not a film to see on
your iPhone and you can't help thinking
that the job of streaming is if that's
what it ends up as But ultimately The
Cinematic experience a very very brief
one that isn't really much interest in
doing deals with the mainstream Cinema
and having these films out so yes I mean
you can see that it's wonderful that big
mainstream filmmakers get the chance to
make films I've always wanted to make
but the trade-off is the Cinematic
experience it's been taken away from
them and I have no idea I mean you
should have a mama Christopher Nolan who
is an absolute evangelist for Cinema but
and I'm saying they're six months away
from release so I might be completely
wrong about this his new thing about
Oppenheimer I'm thinking who's going to
go and see it I mean it'll probably be
brilliant but it that seems to me almost
like a last forever dies a last way of
saying I want to make films for adults
who want to go and see something
challenging something unusual and
something interesting I don't want to go
and make just another superhero film and
when it doesn't do very well at the box
office Nolan will be offered to Apple TV
or to Netflix just like everyone else I
think shame yeah that does sound like a
shame I think particularly because
there's so much to be said about that
experience of going to the cinema of you
know it's a social thing to do with
friends you make a whole occasion of it
popcorn the LA the rest of it um but I
was also wanted to ask you obviously I
can't really talk about films that
talking about award season we're just
getting going for this year so we had
the Golden Globes at the start of the
year then there was the battle
nominations that came out last week and
we're expecting Oscar nominations
tomorrow
any surprises so far from what you've
seen
um I was very surprised for All Quiet on
the Western Front has been nominated for
loads and loads of baftas
it just dropped me as men it's a very
good film there's no reason why it
shouldn't be it just didn't seem
unlikely the bat was going to emerge
from nowhere as being the film but
everyone went mad full
um personific tar should win everything
it's the best one I've seen in years
it's a phenomenal piece of Cinema it's
returned to screens of Todd field had
moved from in 16 years and it has Kate
Blanchard's best performance and that's
saying an awful awful lot but the
problem with this I mean Tara is a kind
of film but doesn't get made very often
it's elliptical strange challenging very
funny film and I'd think that it's
really exciting we can still have a film
like that being made to be released but
it's done nothing of a box office
because it's not a film for mainstream
audiences so all you can hope is that
actually this is where award terminals
become quite useful if a film like that
gets attention when people start to hear
about it they think oh I've got to go
and see that without said I mean last
year of the Oscars nobody remembers what
won best film because everyone thinks
about Will Smith and Chris Rock the fact
that it was coder for one best film
which of course was another streaming
film Nobody remembers it anymore because
it was seen as something that there was
a really good campaign behind it but it
just seems increasingly I mean it used
to be if a film won the best film of the
Oscars it went down in history it became
a big success it became you know it's
titemic film now I mean the last few
films to have won best film of the
Oscars have just faded from view quite
quickly and you ask well is that because
of the makeup of the academy is a much
more diverse makeup is it that they're
deliberately trying to nominate and
indeed award films but appealing to a
different kind of audience or is it that
they're just not picking very good films
because I do feel that the quality of
filmmaking has declined quite
significantly in the past two decades
yeah I think that's a really interesting
question because
um there have obviously been questions
about
diversity and inclusion within the
awards more broadly but for example so
this year the baftas have decided to do
away with some of their gendered
categories so for things I think like
film director but they have retained
some of them and the Oscars have also
said that that's something they'd be
willing to consider in the future just
wondering if you have any thoughts on
that sort of row well for Brits tried
doing this they went horrendously badly
so all you can say is don't do it it's a
really stupid idea because ultimately
you could end up with 10 actors being
nominated rather than five and it but
also I don't think you can really
compare like for like I think that we
could say that it's wrong we could say
that it's stuck in a personal rest of it
but I also feel that actually if it's
absurd situation if you're not ring
fencing male or female performances it's
very easy to start ignoring them I don't
see how something like that's going to
play out very well what might be quite
sad is the sand men do as well regards
the very intelligent man of a thoughtful
man came out the other day though we
shouldn't have these gendered Awards and
I thought well given that your film
Empire of light firstly no one's been to
see it but secondly it's got Olivia
Coleman not giving yet another Olivia
colemanish performance which is normally
for quite a lot of awards for he started
well can't she have a recognition
against her peers like okay planets of
this world I mean how do you really
compare that to say Tom Cruise and Top
Gun and the answer is you can't and you
probably shouldn't well it's yeah
exactly that I think it's interesting
that you know for example at the baftas
all of the nominees for best film were
directed by men and five the six
nominees for best director were men so I
think it's it's an interesting debate
and perhaps not one that we'll see a
definitive answer to for I don't know at
least for the next cycle or the cycle
after that of awards um but it's
definitely one to keep an eye on well
there's too many men working in cinema I
mean there's too many male directors and
it's a great shame because ultimately
it's our most interesting work for the
last few years I mean you could say
power of a dog and during Campion that's
a brilliant film that just shows
Champion equals one best director at the
obstacles for that she'd very much
deserved to so I think we understand but
it it isn't as if it needs to be a male
dominated industry but it is and I think
that is a Pity but I don't know what you
would do to try and make that less of a
case because if you said we are going to
have of a six of a six nominee category
three must be women then you're creating
essentially a kind of ghetto you're
saying well these people are in because
they're women rather because of the
quality of their films and they think no
that shouldn't be the case what should
be the case so there's many many more
female directors who are actually
getting the chance to make brilliant
films and they're competing on that
level on their own merits well thank you
very much for talking to Alexander it's
been a pleasure it's been absolute
pleasure to be here as well thank you
[Music]